在上一段感情当中被背叛被伤害的这样一个不安全感转嫁到现任身上，
是我们女人身上最愚蠢的一个点啊，
但这个点不是你一个人有，
是千千万万的女性都有。
比如说第一个男朋友谈的是个渣男，
劈腿了，
在谈第二个男朋友的时候，
她始终不愿意去相信第二个男朋友会对她忠诚，
她会采取各种各样极端的方式去考验，
去验证第二个男朋友。
我是有一些困惑，
关于分手这个问题，
但我现在没有这个想法，
之前是有这个想法，
还是想连线一下你，
解除我心中的一些困惑，
我真的这么下定去做这个事情的话，
那我需要赔付别人多少钱，
我也不想占别人便宜，
结婚的时候给了彩礼是166000，
买了7万多的黄金对接2万多，
他爸妈在我不之前就要给我买了个车位，
应该是在他名下吧，
我也不知道，
我也没说他房子要加我名，
他们家全款的，
我也没说他们自己给我加上去的，
我呢，
婚前是有一个房子，
首付了50多万，
有房贷100万这样子，
因为我爸妈给我买的房子，
我家里还有个弟弟给我买的房子，
我自己付贷款，
这样子，
车就是老公家给买的，
但是呢，
买的时候是在我的彩礼钱里面扣了个12万出来，
付了个首付，
钱是在我的名下还款的，
这个钱是他还，
就是总共27万，
中间有段时间房子跌价了，
不种我自己存了点钱，
我老公来。
点他钱，
我拉点我的一起还了个45万，
这样子结婚的时候也花了他家挺多钱的，
我看了你的视频，
说不应该铺张浪费，
当时比较铺张浪费，
户外都弄了，
加上车，
加上对戒黄金，
不加车位再加车，
总共花了70多万吧，
就他们家想要生孩子，
但是我不太想生，
我内心很痛苦，
我不知道该怎么办。
你今年是多大，
算下来32岁，
那你说你不想生孩子，
你在结婚之前有跟你的对象，
跟你的公公婆婆说这个事情吗？
公公，
公公婆婆未必要说，
但是你跟你的对象说过吗？
你不想生孩子这个事儿我跟他说了，
我说我不生的原因是有感觉不到，
哎，
我感觉不到你对我的在乎，
各种我希望你能够主动积极，
怎么样，
你这个不叫明说，
你不想生孩子，
你这个是给出一个条件，
要求别人对你好，
潜台词是说你对我好，
我就生孩子，
你并不是说从一开始就表示了你不想生孩，
这是两码事儿，
我其实自己也不知道，
我害怕生完孩子之后会有变化，
各种因为我养猫嘛，
他不是喜欢猫，
也不让猫进房间，
各种会觉得这不是我想要的生活，
我觉得我俩有一些精神方面的问题，
你想不想生孩子，
这首先我得尊重你，
这是你的权利，
但是我们觉得自己的权利的行使要建立在不损害别人权利的基础之上，
那我认为你的这个做法是不妥的。
如果你。
想生孩子，
那么你在婚前就应该明确的坚定的告诉对方，
然后把选择权交到对方的手里，
如果对方能够接受你的丁克，
接受你不生孩子，
那是他的选择，
但你没有，
你只是给出了一个模棱两可的，
就算你现在不想生孩子，
我也能尊重你，
你不想生孩子，
这就是你的权利。
但是在这种情况下的话，
那么我们就要看一下，
我们的这个行为给别人造成了什么损失，
我们该承担什么样的责任，
对不对？
你们结婚时间也不长是吧，
从领证到现在总共多长时间呀，
2年多。
第二，
我家人对你真的是不错，
房子也登记了你的名字，
各种财产，
各种婚礼开销，
也是非常在你的面子，
或者说在乎你的心理诉求的。
那现在就问，
如果要分开的话，
显然会怎么分，
这些财产会怎么分？
那我问一下你心里的预期是希望怎么分呢？
我不知道，
哎，
我其实还是想改善我们两个的关系，
我也去咨询了心理医生，
但是我感觉作用也不大。
你今天想要问我的问题是说离婚分财产怎么分呢？
还是说怎么改善你俩的关系呢？
两个都想知道，
这两个是不同的方向哦，
我也不知道是不是我有问题，
你的原生家庭怎么样？
爸妈是干啥的呢？
我爸妈个体户，
我小时候跟我爷爷奶奶一起长大的，
家里还有别的兄弟姊妹吗？
弟弟家里会重男轻女吗？
有一点点，
但还好，
不过家里大部分财产是给我弟弟的，
相比较其他，
我觉得我爸妈对我已经很好了，
那你爸妈在你结婚的时候为你付出了多少呢？
给了多少嫁妆呢？
给我买了个房子，
50多万都给我，
后面的一些过户啊，
各方面都给我付了钱，
刚工作的时候他们也接济我各种，
那你现在这份工作是体制内吗？
对的，
那男方在结婚这两年当中有做过什么对不起你的事情吗？
有什么伤害你的行为吗？
没有，
就是我俩精神上面情绪上面总是吵架。
男方是干什么工作的呢？
在公司里面大概收入怎么样呢？
2W，
我大概是他的一半，
但现在我俩差不多，
男方父母是干啥的呢？
我也不太清楚，
一点都不想了解人家男方的父母嘛，
她爸妈现在不工作了，
但你之前谈过别的男朋友嘛，
谈了7年，
我觉得我可能到现在还是有点害怕，
我不敢说孩子，
我害怕一些东西，
但是我总是得不到一些答案，
我就更害怕谈7年那个恋爱最后分手是被抛弃还是怎么的被抛弃，
其实姑娘我觉得我们需要解决的课题是自己的课题，
问题还是出在我自己，
这点是出在我们自己身上，
我们这种缺乏安全感，
有可能是在上一段感情当中遭遇的伤害带到了这一段感情当中，
其实这个对现在。
对老公来说是非常不公平的，
而且是愚蠢的。
对于我们女人来说，
把在上一段感情当中被背叛被伤害的这样一个不安全感转嫁到现任身上，
是我们女人身上最愚蠢的一个点啊。
但这个点不是你一个人有，
是千千万万的女性都有。
比如说第一个男朋友谈的是个渣男，
劈腿了，
在谈第二个男朋友的时候，
她始终不愿意去相信第二个男朋友会对她忠诚，
她会采取各种各样极端的方式去考验，
去验证第二个男朋友。
我给大家举过一个例子，
这个例子非常典型，
就好像是有一个方桌，
女生想试验一下这个桌子的腿儿结不结实，
女生就站了上去，
站上去了之后能沉住女生的重量，
但是女生还是不死心，
还是不相信，
就让他的妈妈站了上去，
但是这个桌子还是沉住了，
他们俩的重女生还是不小心，
想试一下这个桌子稳不稳，
又让他的爸爸站了上去，
这个时候桌子就断了。
我讲这个故事是想要告诉你，
如果你自己不解决你自己内心对第一个男朋友的那种失望，
抛弃被伤害的那种创伤的话，
你跟任何一个男人在一起的时候，
你都会采取这种方式去验证对方，
最终的结果只能是被抛弃，
所以我有时候在想，
我是不是适合一个人过，
我们每一个人最终在这世间都是修炼一个课题就是我怎么能变得越来越好。
不是说我遇到了困难，
我。
被伤害了，
马上就得出一个极端的答案，
说我一个人过，
是我怎么能修炼的越来越好，
我怎么能修炼到，
还是相信这个世间好人多，
善意更多。
讲这个事情有点动情了啊，
像龙飞，
我自己从小长大的过程当中，
经历过各种各样的伤害，
你们能想象得到的什么姐，
什么其他的方面的伤害我都经历过，
但我还是相信这个世界上一定是好人正常人更多，
你必须要这样修炼自己，
不然的话，
你就败给了那个伤害你的人，
你就让那个伤害你的人抛弃你的人，
在你的世界里成为了冠军，
不能允许，
因为他时很奇怪，
我不知道为什么我结婚当天那个人，
我把所有联系方式删掉，
他不知道为什么有我的淘宝，
他给我发了一段一大段，
我已经不记得他说什么，
我把他删了，
我就觉得这个人很奇怪，
纯恶心人，
他比较奇怪，
他恶心人，
有些人就是我的朋友恶心人，
还认识他，
他还跟我的朋友说什么，
谈了个我各种怎么样，
我觉得很奇怪，
这件事一直想不通，
所以我觉得你现在需要做的不是说立马去离婚，
去分财产，
你需要做的是如果一个心理医生，
如果一个情感主播，
一个情感导师没有办法解你的套的话，
就多找几个人，
必须要自己解套，
必须要把自己修补了之后，
你才有可能有一段比较顺利的关系。
可能当时比较冲动了，
对别人也不太好，
你就像那个想要去验证这个桌子的腿儿会不会断的女生一样，
我觉得可能是我，
我觉得你把这个精力放在工作上，
我觉得可能工作是最稳妥的，
是修炼自己，
我明白了，
那我也就不要这样子了，
就是假设我最终觉得还是过不下去，
我就得也不要耽误了，
因为他说过，
他觉他是想要说话，
就是啊，
他没有直接说，
但是我大概懂了，
他意思就是说，
如果一直不生或者怎么样，
他也是不想一直下去，
那只能理解人家是吧，
我知道，
那如果这样的话，
那我假设一下，
那我要赔付他多少钱，
也不存在赔付的问题，
别人的东西咱就别想着分别人的财产了吧，
那如果是他爸爸妈妈出钱买的房子，
只不过是登了我们的名字的话，
鉴于男方没有任何的过错，
对我也没有什么伤害，
在这种情况下的话，
我就不要你的钱，
我也不要你的补偿，
我可以把这个我借我一贷，
我俩一起提前还，
在这个部分还给他就好了。
我的理解是这样，
因为做人和法律他还是有一定的鸿沟的，
虽然说从法律上来说，
他给你付出的，
他给你的彩礼钱，
婚礼这些支付啊，
法律上来说很难退的回去，
但从情理上来讲，
毕竟人家对我没有造成伤害，
人家没有亏恤我，
没有欺骗我，
那在这种情况下的话，
如果是以我自己的做事做人的风格的话，
是你的钱我不会占你的便宜，
那么就算。
就完事了，
车子的钱给他退给人家，
退给的他还的部分退给他他们办了婚礼的钱了，
办婚礼的钱花掉了就是花掉了啊，
我跟他说了很久，
说了我的原生家庭，
各种爷爷奶奶各种，
但是他没有给我很多答，
我就觉得好像没有用，
我就自己治愈了大概很久，
后来觉得又不清，
就一直反反复，
因为我现在有时候睡不着，
吃安眠药这种我觉得是这样的姑娘啊，
心理上的扣有的时候也是拼缘分，
看你能不能遇到铁扣的人。
我在网上也经常会刷到一些心理医生他们接诊的那些画面，
有的心理医生给我的感觉就是我觉得他是公式化的，
甚至是沽名钓誉的，
甚至是故意扒开别人的伤口来赚流量的，
但是有一些人会给我的感觉，
我能够感受到他心底的善良，
我能够感受到他内心深处滋生出来的慈悲，
所以人和人之间就是要讲缘分的，
那你需要去多找几个，
找不同的心理咨询师，
多去找是真的，
人和人就是要拼这个缘分，
那你就是要去拼，
你看到他，
你就莫名的信任他，
你就相信他说的话，
你要找这样的人，
我要去试试吗？
对，
要多找啊，
好，
好谢谢，
这里说谢谢，
好，
再见啊，
谢谢。
其实我有的时候我也会反过头来想，
可能我觉得人家沽名钓誉，
我觉得人家虚伪的人，
人家也未必是。
对的，
只是我和他之间没有这种生命的链接，
没有这种缘分而已。
同样的道理，
像我自己，
比如说我直播间现在11000人，
我也相信大概有一部分人，
他觉得我是虚伪的，
觉得我是沽名钓誉的，
觉得我是故意制作这些冲突，
故意去挑起对立，
为了赚钱，
为了赚流量的，
也一定有一部分人他就是这么认为的，
那这一部分人和我之间就没有这样的生命共鸣和链接，
没有这样的缘分。
但与此同时，
也有一部分人，
他从第一眼看到我的时候，
哪怕其他人都在骂我，
都在质疑我，
但是他就是相信我，
他觉得龙飞姐是掏心掏肺的，
就觉得龙飞姐是发自内心的去解决问题的人，
那就证明我们之间是有这样的生命共鸣和链接，
我们之间是有这样的缘分的，
真的，
人和人之间的关系就是这样。
刚刚有个朋友说，
你不骂这个女的几句吗？
我凭什么骂人家，
人家是我的客户，
人家为我花了钱，
我不能端起碗来吃饭，
放下碗来骂娘吧？
就算是说我要批评的话，
我也是带着说，
希望你今天能听懂龙飞姐讲的这个话，
希望你以后能明白，
能变得更好，
能过得更好，
也是这样，
对不对？
我就算是说说了几句批评的话的话，
我的目的也只能说听进我的批评，
听进去我说的这个话，
你以后才有好日子过，
也必须是这个出发点。
才对，
记得点赞关注哦。